donald trump faces 33 years in prison
for
just what the doj is investigating him
for
as well as the loss of his ability to
hold public office that is the maximum
possible penalty for donald trump based
on what he is being investigated for uh
there are basically three elements to
this and we're going to look at each of
them you've got the espionage act
if trump is found guilty of violating
the espionage act he would pay face
fines and up to 10 years in prison
now the search warrant
from friday cites 18 us code 793 that's
a part of the espionage act which refers
to the quote gathering transmitting or
losing defense information
some of the stock the documents
reportedly relate to nuclear weapons
so
if charged for that violation trump
could be looking at fines and up to 10
years in prison part two of this
investigation in connection with the fbi
search warrant served at mar-a-lago is
concealment of documents
there we are looking at possible fines
and up to three years in prison the
warrant points to 18 u.s code 2071
that's on the quote concealment removal
or mutilation generally and based on
that provision it is illegal to take
government documents it makes it a crime
for anyone to have any federal record in
their possession with the intent to
either conceal or destroy so if charged
there if convicted trump's looking at a
fine or three years in prison but very
importantly and this is why 2071 has
been a big deal over the last few days
if trump is found guilty there he could
be disqualified from holding any public
office in the future could be very
relevant in 2024 and then the third
element here is obstruction of justice
possible fines and up to 20 years in
prison admittedly most people don't get
20 years for obstruction of justice but
that would be 18 us code 1519
that deals with the quote destruction
alteration or falsification of records
in federal investigations and bankruptcy
you are also forbidden from destroying
federal records and this is the highest
potential sentence the 20-year sentence
and um fines are relatively modest now
we are many many steps from anybody
talking about prison time but this is if
we're if the question is being asked
what is the most that we could be
looking at for what the doj is
investigating remember there's the
georgia investigation there's all these
other things forget about that just for
what doj is investigating if trump was
found guilty in all three of these areas
if he got the stiffest sentence and if
the sentences ran uh consecutively
rather than concurrently
you could be looking at 33 years
fines and loss of ability
disqualification from holding public
office is it likely that we would ever
get to that the answer is no but the
next step would be
indictment
then you would have trial slash plea
if you get guilty verdicts then you have
sentencing appeals okay so this is a
very very long road but at the end of
this path
the absolute maximum would be that the
33 years fines can't run for public
office if you believe trump will ever
see anything like that or even a day
behind uh prison bars
let me know
i still don't see it want to let
everybody know wednesday august 31st we
will be doing our members only town hall
this is a member benefit that we used to
do more regularly we got away from it
we've done a bunch of regular town halls
wednesday october august 31st at 6 p.m
eastern 3 p.m pacific we will be doing a
members only town hall
opening the phone lines to our website
members if you'd like to participate
among all the other great member
benefits that there are you can sign up
at
joinpacman.com more on that later and in
the week's upcoming
the david pakman show's longest running
sponsor is blinkist the app that takes
thousands of non-fiction books boils
each of them down into an explainer you
can read or listen to in 15 minutes
blinkist also condenses episodes of
popular podcasts into 15-minute
explainers i've been using blinkist for
years to supplement the books i read i
love reading i i read all the time but
there's even more books i don't have
time to read
and you can often find those non-fiction
books on blinkist and consume the entire
thing in 15 minutes my favorite new
feature on the app is blinkist connect
which lets you share your blinkist
premium account with someone else you
basically get two accounts for the price
of one and then you can also share
blinkist books and podcasts between
users i have a joint blinkist premium
account with my girlfriend
blinkistconnect lets us sync together
what books and podcasts we're listening
to on blinkist sparks many interesting
discussions we just listened to robert
green's the 48 laws of power the new
version robert greene super interesting
writer find his books fascinating you
can try blinkist free for seven days and
get 25 off a premium subscription at
blinkist.com david pakman the link is
down below